this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you Lucas for that introduction
and
um it's really really been a great
experience to work in your lab and and
Kelly Robbins Labs um and I learned so
much about programming and genomics and
databases from you and also how to run
kind of a Agile development team in your
lab and in Cali's lab I learned so much
about quantitative genetics and I'm
really grateful for him
um for like guiding my research into
phenomics
and um as Lika said a little bit about
me
um I went to the University of Florida
before migrating here to Cornell and the
boys Thompson Institute
and my co-advisors are Lucas and Kelly
and my graduate committee
um has Joe Guinness from the Department
of statistics and Harold Mathis vaness
from the soil and crop science section
of sips
and my those were for minors and in
stats and environmental information
science
and um I'm just very happy to
um have recently been married to my
better half I've been just really
thankful for her and all her support
um so I wanted to start with like a
little thought experiment that
um had a big impact on me early on and
it has to do with
um the outcomes of genetically identical
individuals so say you had a handful of
of genetically identical identical
individuals and you were able to
tell them to go live in just in places
and then a year later you were to
measure something about about these
individuals like
um you know something complex like how
many books did they read that year or
something like that and of course you
wouldn't
you wouldn't be able to measure the same
value for any of those individuals and
we know it has to do with um
the environment and the genotype by
environment interactions and in plant
breeding we're presented with a a very
good system for studying these
interactions because we routinely
um are able to evaluate individuals that
are genetically uniform across a lot of
replicates and locations and years
um and the plants can't move so they
have to adapt directly where they are
but um this presents a a challenge for
plant breeding because
as a plant breeder you're interested in
identifying lines that have beneficial
alleles and ultimately have beneficial
phenotypes
um
but um so here I'm illustrating yield on
the y-axis with which is of course a
very important economic and agronomic
trait in a lot of crops
um and then on the x-axis I have a span
of locations and so we could say that
line two is is performing more stably
than line one because its slope is uh is
is less than the deviations
of line one are greater across the
environments
um
but um also in plant breeding
the how we Define the x-axis here can
can vary so these locations they could
be across different geographies they
could be across different field
experiments or clusters of field
experiments
um and it could even be within the same
field so if you if you had that many
replications in in the same field
you could see the stability of the lines
and um ultimately if we if we want to
um look if we want to study how the
plants are interacting with their
environment it's important that we
measure growth and other growth
characteristics across the season and so
for instance in Maize
um you know we we start with the
emergence and the vegetative growth and
then leading up to the kernel
development and grain filling and
ultimately
um the dry down in senescence at the end
of the season
but um
to understand these interactions we
should we should get more growth
characteristics across the season
and ultimately we want to use those
Dynamic growth and environmental factors
that we collect across the season to
help us model and predict the production
traits at the end of the season so
things like grain yield which we you
know which is measured at the end of the
season at Harvest
um
and of course
um this these improving our modeling
approaches is important for you know the
larger challenges of growing population
and um climate change and so on
and
um so the genomic selection is a is a is
a powerful framework in plant breeding
and we can summarize it as having three
components so the the first is
um the informatics component and this is
driven by a genomic prediction
the second component here
um is the variety development pipeline
so this is a a site a general
generational cycle where
um the breeder is is selecting for for
lines that
um that have been ultimately have
beneficial alleles and driving those
beneficial alleles to a fixation in the
population
and ultimately having you know
beneficial phenotypes and then in the
third
um phase we have we can have this Rapid
Cycling which
um essentially
um allows us to survey the the better
survey the alleles and the in the
population
and um my work
um it's mostly focused
within say this green slice here
um and um so this the VDP it's
Illustrated as this cone because in in
very broadly speaking we're at the
beginning of a reading program you start
by testing many many lines say thousands
of lines in very few environments and
then as you're as you're selecting your
your then testing few lines in many many
environments and then ultimately at the
at the tip is where the
you know the few lines that are actually
selected for release for production and
Commercial purposes
um but my work is it's really focused on
like a single
kind of moment in in this EDP
um and looking at the stability kind of
within that evaluation
and so I wanted to start with the info
with uh the informatics piece that I
worked on
um but before that I for people who
aren't really familiar with field
experiments I wanted just to give a an
illustration of one and so this is an
image of a mace experiment
um as if you're looking from above
and
um in this field there were about 200
maze lines
um randomly distributed across 500 field
plots
and these field plots were two row
plantings and I just Illustrated two red
boxes to illustrate some plots in the
field
and there's a lot of metadata Associated
to this field experiment things like the
location so where this was planted
um the the design so the how the
germplasm were actually distributed in
this field
um things like if there were herbicide
or fungicide treatments
um
the pedigrees of parentage of the lines
of course today we have more and more
genomic data so single nucleotide
polymorphism sort of snips that are
called for the germplasm
and we have the phonomics so things like
plant height that we collect at the end
of the season and increasingly things
like imagery and other sensor data
and um also we know that the soil soil
is not uniform in this field so it plays
an important part as well as the the
weather that we uh we have you know
temperature precipitation data collected
across the season
and um so in in Lucas's lab we've
developed this breed-based system for
managing and aggregating all of these
different types of plant breeding data
and um it was it's been a great
experience
and um just really thankful for everyone
who was a part of that and continues to
develop on it
um
one important piece of the of this
database is the genomic data piece
um and we we made an extension to the to
the schema of the database by adding two
Json objects
um I won't go into much detail but we
have a publication showing
um that the in this Json object we we
housed all we house all of the genotype
calls for a given sample and in the
protocol prop we house all of the
information about the mark the markers
and the marker profile that was
um genotyped
and then and then um of course with
within the shadow schema um we have the
genotypes linked to the phenotypes and
linked to the field experiments and so
on
um
in this paper we did a benchmark to show
the speed of of this genotype model and
I I tested it with three
genotype by sequencing or GBS data sets
um so here it was a diploid cassava
diploid Maze and a triploid banana data
set that we had
um and the the the download query time
was
um was suitable for what what we needed
we we made we improved on the speed a
bit by
um using a cache system
um
but the the important thing or the main
point I think in in this data model was
that it fully implements the variant
call format so the VCF spec
and that allows storage of of any
genotype any variant that can be stored
in VCF
um so that uh that's a bit of the
informatics and next I wanted to get
into the genomic prediction piece of it
um so the kind of the Baseline genomic
prediction model it um it's a linear
mixed model that allows us to use
genomic relationships
um so in this in this model uh Y is the
trait of Interest so y can be brain
yield say
um beta is the fixed effects so those
are often like design factors like
replication
um you is is the random genetic effect
and we model the variance of you to
follow a genomic relationship Matrix
um this this relationship Matrix is um
computed from the whole genome snip data
that we have
for so for the tested lines
um and this this relationship Matrix as
it's Illustrated here allows us to see
like the kinship between lines and um so
these lines at the bottom are are
queries uh related to each other and we
can see other
uh clusters of of that kinship
but um ultimately the the utility of
this model is we can predict things like
grain yield
um using the genomic data
we can improve on this model by
accounting for spatial
uh space like a spatial correction
and to do this we use the kind of the
ordinal row and column position of the
plots in the field
um so like for instance this plot is in
Row 2 column 10 and this plot is in uh
row six column 40 something like that
and then we can make the assumption that
plots that are close to each other will
experience similar spatial Trends
um or more similar spatial Trends than
plots that are far away from each other
and the
so the reason we want to include this
spatial correction is because we know
that there's spatial heterogeneity in
the field so we know that there's
different soil types different soil
moisture salinity
water retention
um elevation and curvature across the
field
and so this model allows us to estimate
those effects
and exploring this spatial heterogeneity
sets the stage for looking at stability
within the same field
Manchester so mathematically how how
that it's the same model as before with
the with the random genetic effects but
now we have a random plot level effect
here
um and I used uh two two two methods for
estimating this spatial correction the
first was a separable auto regressive
model using
um as rmlr and the second was a
two-dimensional spline model using our
um so the the data I used in my research
came from the genomes to Fields
initiative and um the g2f is a large
multi-institution
meios project
um it's organized out of Iowa State
University and University of Wisconsin
Madison
um and with with collaborators across
the across the U.S
um
we evaluate mace hybrids in a variety of
locations and this um this project
promotes the development of new
phenotyping tech new phenotyping methods
as well as like the development of new
model modeling techniques
and uh really grateful for Nick and
Sinta for helping me understand that the
data we have going back to 2014
um up to this year
so the the agronomic traits that I I was
interested in it were the grain yield
the grain moisture and the ear height
um
and if we apply the spatial that spatial
correction model that I just mentioned
we can start to see the like the field
heterogeneity
um and so these heat maps are as if
you're looking at the field from above
so each cell is a plot in the field and
the y-axis is the columns and the x-axis
is the rows
um and so for for grain yield we can see
um
deviations of plus or minus 25 bushels
per acre so what that's representing is
plots that were planted here are
experiencing this spatial uh like a
minus 25 bushels per acre we see a
similar spatial Trend with ear height
um like plus or minus 15 centimeters
and then we see kind of an inverted
pattern with brain moisture
of a plus or minus one percent
um I looked at at four other or three
other field experiments so in 2015 2017
and 2019 and similar magnitudes of
spatial effect were were seen
and this relationship between the traits
of similar results for or similar
patterns for ear height and brain yield
and then an inverted pattern of brain
moisture
um those were visible in all those years
as well
but now um so we we want as I said in
the beginning we want to
um include growth growth parameters
across the growing season
um and we want we want to use those
Dynamic variables to help our
predictions of the end of season uh
say granule at the end of the season
and to do that we flew
um an unoccupied aerial vehicles or uavs
over our field experiments
um and this is going back to 2015 and
I'm really I'm really thankful for Nick
casmar and Nick santantonio for teaching
me how to fly the Drone operate the
Drone
um and grateful for Nick lepack
um for helping me coordinate those
flights in the field because we don't
want to fly the Drone while other
things are going on in the field
um these uavs are equipped with a
multi-spec camera so we use the mic
sense five channel camera and it
captures in the blue green red Redditch
and near infrared
um and uh this is the the camera we use
with the five separate lenses
there's a lot of you know phenotypes you
could potentially get from these cameras
but um for my work I specifically looked
at ndbi and it ndvi's just calculated as
a ratio using the near infrared and the
the red
and um ntvi has been shown many times to
to be able to differentiate vegetation
um because of productive chlorophyll
will reflect in the near infrared and
absorb in the red
um ndbi has the benefit of being a ratio
so it's from zero to one and
um
and it's uh uh it's been shown in many
many times to be predicted for
vegetation
um to process all of this imagery by uh
developed this image read
imagebreed software
and it's a it's a program for taking the
images that are collected and turning
them into like numerical plot level
values
um and this so this is a like a
three-step process
um in imagebreed so the the first step
is to take the the captured images off
of the the Drone and then to to uh
transform them into a Ortho mosaic
and an ortho Mosaic is a stitched like
composite image of the entire field
um so it's a it's as if you're looking
at the field from above
then um I then apply I apply a rotation
to the ortho Mosaic so that the plots
are aligned vertically
and Then followed up with a cropping so
just to remove uh for instance the the
road that was here on the left side of
the image
and then finally to
um
template the plot polygons
and so in this template each of these
rectangles represents the plot a plot in
the field
and from that we can then get a
numerical a numerical value
and save it in the database
and and all of this is implemented
um just as a point and click
um pretty simple point and click system
um there's been some good adoption and
like seeing adoption of the tools
um both breed bass and imagebreed is is
really a rewarding thing and a big
motivator
um and currently in in here in this
instance we have a lot of Alfalfa and
mace images
um a little bit of barley or some barley
and some hemp now and also some rice
images from a researcher at Erie that is
just interested in in using new tools
that are available
and here here I just wanted to highlight
kind of the exponential nature of high
throughput phenotyping because so we'll
have we have the 43 field experiments
um so roughly 10 10 Imaging events per
field here on average
and then that that kind of explodes
um into several million images and plots
um just because so many there's so many
field plots
and so many uh Spectra and all of those
things
But ultimately
um what we get from this image breed
from this high throughput phenotyping
process is we can find we can start to
see we can start to measure
characteristics across the growing
season so here on the x-axis is days
after planting and on the wise ndvi
and even using just the the mean so
these curves are just the average ndvi
for these lines and we can start to see
the the classic
um emergence at the beginning followed
by brain filling at the plateau and dry
down and senescence at the end
and um so that this is that was exciting
to see that we can we can measure and
observe these things
now how to incorporate this into into
our genomic prediction
we can use a multi-trade model as a
mallet and Kelly Robin's lab showed and
there's there is high genetic
correlation between grain yield and ndvi
so above 0.6 in in most years
um but we we did see a residual
correlation between brain yield and mdbi
in in some experiments so um there is
the original residual correlation could
be an issue if
um or we can we can look to separate the
residual correlation
from
um a spatial effect
and so that that's what I did next I I
looked at the spatial effects in these
traits separately so again these heat
maps are as if you're looking at the
field from above
each cell is a plot in the field
we see grain yield it goes from zero to
300 bushels per acre
we see the spatial effect of the spatial
effect
um impacting drain yields
and then here I'm showing the spatial
effect impacting
the ndvi measurement at 38 days after
planting
um and so if we do this across the whole
growing season
we start to see that the
this ndvi spatial effects
are they are correlated to the
spatial effect impacting grain yield
um and even at 54 days after planting
um we have a correlation of of 0.7
so even early on these uh the the plot
the the plot level environmental effect
can be resolved
um we we went a step further and we
wanted to model these
um model these effects in a a continuous
in a continuous way and so the random
regression model allows us to fit a
continuous covariance function
for both the random genetic effect and
the this random plot level effect
so ultimately what we get from this
model is a is a continuous curve for
each of the genotypes
or each of the lines and we get a
continuous curve for each of the plots
and um in the in the literature the this
uh plot level effect is called the
permanent environment
but it it it's in it's indicate it's
indicative of the same type of
environmental effect that I was looking
at with the spatial
models I showed
and um just to show just to summarize
how these different models are
performing
um relative to
how well can they detect
um the spatial effect impacting drain
yield so
um I'm showing that the models in this
red box they tend to tend to correlate
well with the with the spatial effects
of grain yield
um particularly early on in the in the
season
um
and so that this this tells us that um
um ndvi is is capturing similar spatial
effects as the as what's impacting grain
yield
and um
in 2019 we wanted to see if we could
give some explanation for these effects
um to the statistical effects we were
seeing so we we did a em-38 soil survey
um of the field
and
um
on the right here are are interpolated
um interpolated plots of the electrical
conductance and the elevation
and um so electrical conductance is
known to be linked to of many soil
parameters things like water retention
and salinity and soil soil composition
to
um
and so we were hopeful that this could
uh give us insight into the spatial
effects we were seeing
and again if we look at these heat Maps
um as if you're looking at the field
from above
this is uh for electrical conductance
and elevation here
and I looked at the derivatives of of
these measurements
um and I did that because we thought
curvature curvature would uh
be a better explanatory variable
um
and if if we uh combine that with what
we saw before
um we can see that one number one we see
that uh and this is showing the same
thing as before that the spatial effect
in Grain yield is is correlated to the
spatial effect in ndvi
um number two is showing that the soil
electrical conductance
um does it correlates up to 0.5 with the
ndvi effects
and with the soil
um with the derivatives of soil
we see a correlation up to 0.3 with
those ndbi spatial effects
and so to some to some degree the the
soil is is impacting these what we're
seeing
now um the final piece here was how does
this all
um help us with genomic prediction and
with stability of these lines
and um so the way the way we looked at
this was to apply a spatial correction
using the models I just described to
each of the replicates
and if if the model is doing a good job
you'd expect the model to
eliminate kind of the latent
environmental effect and so you'd be
able to get the same genetic effect for
each of the replicates
um when I compare the models to the
Baseline uh genomic prediction model
we see that
the spatial spatial correction models I
showed at the very beginning they do
improve our measure of stability
um however if we add so these other
models here are
um
are have the ndvi effect incorporated
into them
um I I tried two approaches both using
incorporating them as random effect
random variants and as fixed effects
and it was shown that
um here using using the random
regression
um the random regression
uh
permanent environment had had the
greatest uh impact on improving our
measure of stability
um here here I just validated it with
heritability to make sure that the
the magnitude of those genetic effects
was still
you know was still strong
and um
so in summary the um the spatial effects
they were detectable to a large degree
by ndvi
the soil electrical conductance and
um and this curvature estimate uh did
correlate to some degree with that ndvi
local environment
and we were able to improve our
um genomic prediction heritability and
stability
um
above that of even the traditional
spatial correction
and um
after all this work
um it might be surprising to say that I
think we need more models
um
because
um to really act to really bring in all
of these new data points that we're
getting uh from both uh ground Rovers
and aerial drones I think we'll need to
incorporate uh neural network models and
I'm excited to work with Joe Gage and
Aaron farmer and um Mike Gore and
ying-san in
um in in the future as a postdoc
um just to give some small things I I
think I learned as a grad student
I think it's very important to to work
on questions that are interesting to you
and um read and look for gaps in
knowledge that
um you can
you can research on
and um
just want to thank everyone who's been
involved
especially my funding sources
um thank everyone in the Robin's lab and
Mueller lab and of course my family
who's helped me the whole the whole time
and with that I'll take any questions
ask you
uh the need for protecting you for kind
of machine learning
deep learning neural network approaches
do you see that as as being
um so there's kind of two challenges
here one is going from
pixelated image that's capturing you
know multiple wavelengths down to some
quantitative phenotype that has a
relationship with some
agronomic adventures and the Second
Challenge is I'm certain how to deal
with longitudinal data and potentially
High dimensional data in your
predictions where do you see neural
networks finding the biggest role
um in that and where do you see kind of
the the biggest gaps in terms of our
ability to use
genotyping for prediction right now
um yeah so
um so repeat the question was about
um
was about using the neural networks and
and what role do they play
um
and I think
um
the the necessity comes from the fact
that we have so many data points so
um you have these uh large you know you
have images so these are thousands of
pixels or you have
um like a point Cloud representation of
the plant and
um in order to
uh
in order to derive like
um meaning from from that data
um you need a model that can
that can uh
uh fully you know fully
fully um account for for
the the variances and and other things
you're seeing
um
but I I think
um
I think uh what from from work I've seen
uh from Joe Gage and uh he he used an
auto encoder neural network to go from
the
um go from the pixel image data
to to a latent representation of
of the the
um phenotype of interest and so that
that approach is more like
of like a phenotype extraction method so
you're you're just you're looking for
some way to summarize the data into
um
like a numeric value that you can you
can then work with
um but I think with I think uh to move
forward I think um
the the neural network should
encapsulate like going from the image
data
um all the way to like the prediction of
your trait of interest
um so that you you know you can use the
full
gradient gradient descent and all that
of of the model
and um
especially today you can even
incorporate
um
like
quantitative genetic models into that
process so things like the genomic
variants that we saw
um
like that can that can be incorporated
into a neural net as well
I was sort of prepared to do it during
the uh the exam later on but but I think
maybe one question would be a broader
interest that that sort of you you use
two sort of data sources to correlate
with yield mostly uh and one was your uh
your early season uh ndvi which I I
thought that's pretty good correlation
0.7 that's really quite nice uh if you
can do it that early in the season and
the other one was
um of course your soil data your em38
based data
um so
what if you had measured this for
another season when the weather
conditions were quite different let's
say I don't know whether it was wet year
or a dry year when you did it but let's
say it was sort of opposite weather
conditions so would your ndvi data to
show you
similar patterns
and would your soil data show similar
patterns yeah I I wish we could have or
I would have looked at that
um here I just showed so I had one data
point of soil I've had one
one field experiment in 2019
so
um
so I wasn't able to to Really
demonstrate that but I I would I mean I
would
um
I would predict that you know the ndvi
would capture it similarly
um
and then with the data I looked at it's
very hard to tell because the the four
years of experiments that I looked at
they were all planted in different
actual actually different
um
pieces of land so like the em-38 that we
had could only apply it to one of them
um but in I think this year we this year
we did do another em-38
um but I I had I didn't I haven't looked
at the data for that
yeah
there's in sort of precision agriculture
they're not in your area in terms of you
know looking at um reading opportunities
there is a lot of interest in this sort
of precision management and the emphasis
has been more on measuring soils
um but you know measuring you know early
season ndvi seems really promising so uh
I think there's going to be companies
offering those kind of services
yeah yeah yeah I I I I I I hope to go
back and look at it we we do have this
from this year and so if if you know
both years show similar correlations
then
that would that would be promising
yeah
so how long did it take to do the soil
measurements the CC
um like in a say an acre how how long
does that take yeah I
um it it was from what I heard it was a
pretty difficult process
um uh Nick Nick casmar did it
um
but yeah because it's it's a pretty
heavy probe and so he was walking in a
serpentine this way and then a
serpentine this way so I think it took
you know
like the whole I don't know it took the
whole day I would imagine
um we we started the Outsource set now
to uh
they're affiliated with I think very
scary
um but they they drag it off on like a
little sleds but yeah we're not
We're not gonna do the handheld yeah
yeah Jerry won right
what's the component of the EC I mean
it's correlated with
um mineral contents or what's the reason
yeah
um so the soil EC is pretty complex it's
a it's a pretty complex measurement
um it it measures a variety I mean it's
it's impacted by a variety of things
definitely the soil composition and
um like the water retention or I mean uh
soil moisture can play a big part
um
and um
so yeah the reason the reason why it is
correlating higher to the ndbi
um
I I believe it has to do with the
um with that water retention
so
um
areas of the field that are you know
um
uh like have have experiencing more
um kind of inundation will experience a
lower
um yield and and that can be that can
transmit through the ndvi
this idea of genetic stability the
different slopes and then and then this
facial correction you showed that it
increased the correlation between rep
one and rep2 but could you use the the
you know the spatial map and then rep
one and rep2 to extract
like genotype specific stability across
the two uh the two reps and and if you
tried that you think that would have any
heritability at all
even like
um you mean like say just seeing the
deviation between the Reps or something
like that yeah
um
uh I didn't look at that um but I I'd
imagine
um
to look at that it'd be I think it'd be
if we had more more than two reps it'd
be great
um
because for this it was just two
replicates but foreign
I'd imagine it's there's heritability
there
um I think you've shown earlier in your
presentation the power of
standardization and breed Grace and
property and everything
I'm wondering what your thoughts are on
autoencoders though with all these
different data sets because I mean my
concern is the input coming in
which is not standardized
and uh and so you create a model
it's used it's a one-off tech model and
you know I can understand your building
mammogram machines and you're selling
you know you're going to sell 100 000 of
them then do you have standardization
through that type of product using a lot
of encoders but in our type of context
where do you yeah what's your thought on
standardization in Auto encoders and
that type of thing
um yeah well I think with the auto
encoder I mean with auto encoders you
have you run into problems
um like uh just in training the models
like uh do you include all of the time
points do you
um do you just train an auto encoder
like specifically for a specific
a part of the growth you know of the
like when all the plants
um you know
have reached a certain stage so
like uh I think standardizing how you
train the model would
play a big part there
um
because the like the the sensors we have
they they are standardized
um
and so
uh if you know in in these databases we
we
try to organize the incoming data as
best we can
um and uh that includes you know
separating it by location by time and so
on so I I think I think the bigger part
of that standardization would come from
how you're building these models
um
so
vegan do not like these plots right
but there's natural inoculum up in
Aurora it closely comes in after
flowering sea of those nice correlations
with the odbi and you know pre-flowering
I was wondering if anyone took um if
you're looking to get soil moisture and
soil did you look at disease and I'll
see if there's any correlation any basic
disease
disease yeah unfortunately
um on so I was I looked at the nyh2 and
the nyh2 experiment
um and that was not uh inoculated
um hey like you said but
um and I don't think we I don't think we
collected
um disease scores on on those fields
um
so unfortunately I
I can't uh
can't say but
um
I know I know um well yeah if I think I
think on the J field like where the
inoculations happen right like I think
there was some uh some drone data so we
could look at that right how does ndbi
correlate with disease score but
on the fields I looked at I didn't have
that data so
related to Auto encoders so obviously
vegetation indices suffering properties
right and you could run those through an
audit incubator but what if you just ran
like the five bands from the sensor
through an auto encoder before even
calculating the vegetation you know do
you think there's value in doing that
then you wouldn't have to calculate them
yeah yeah I think um
I think you would want to
start with the the raw I mean the the
the data coming off of the camera
sensors
um and to to feed that in into the into
these Auto encoders but
um like you mentioned one of the
one of the great things with ntbi is it
it is a ratio so like uh if if say on
day one it's like kind of dark outside
and then on day two it's like full sun
so you with the ratio you can you know
you you eliminate those kind of
large environmental impact on your
measurement
um so in your autoencoder I think
you'd want to feed you know
like feed the different Spectra and
um
and um
uh like if because if if if you're just
looking at one band you wouldn't be able
to see this ratio
and um so yeah I think it's it's really
important that you use all of the
all of the bands at the same time or at
least some of the Bands
there's a question online
personal live yes
with these images work for and balance
experimental designs
uh specific in design yeah and balance
oh
it's experimental design yeah
um so this uh special the spatial
correction can be done on a unbalanced
design
um and the random regression can also be
done on an unbalanced design
um
so but if you're looking at if you're
trying to look at this stability across
replicates
um then you might have an issue
with an unbalanced
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu